Stephanie what was your first meeting
with John like I so remember it because
I was trying to replace myself in the
story department at Columbia Pictures
and allegedly he wanted the job as a
reader as a reader that's right so he
came in but he really did not want the
job at all he just wanted to tell me
about this script he'd written boys in
the hood and he was still in college he
was a senior I guess but he'd already
won the prestigious Jack Nicholson award
I begged him for the script I went to
school in Inglewood so I I was like
it'll please let me have the script and
he said no John Hughes has it I saw what
John Hughes had John here's a yeah yeah
who's gonna be in it like what rake chef
okay what's gonna happen with it we gave
I'm candy cuz I love John Hughes I just
John he was a sighs I don't teenager you
know he's John used with John Hughes and
then is also uh
in Juicin right no no not job no
dressing I'm a guy sound silly and
Jonathan Demme II John Denver one
diverse or - I don't know what happen
I'm gonna be beggin back he already had
an agent at CA so I was just call every
day and say hey I want to have that boys
in the script boys the hood script
please send it finally I don't know it
was like two weeks later three weeks
later the script arrived I was like so
excited this is when you know you
actually got a script hard script yeah I
close the door to my little office I
read it from cover to cover and I was
just sobbing I was just so just it was
the big aha moment I was like oh my god
this is what I have to do this this is
the movie that we have to make and I
called him and said hey let's do this
and then he said oh okay good because he
directed a couple a couple little things
at school and and the big thing was I'm
not giving the script I'm not selling
the script I'm directing the script and
just from the get-go he was so positive
about that y'all ain't getting this my
favorites used to say I'm not gonna have
somebody from Idaho or I see you know
direct this movie yeah I'm not gonna
make it up I'm not gonna mess this one
up so wait a minute John Hughes I don't
have to get after asking to get John
Hughes head is good I like Johnny
movies I like Ferris Bueller there's
awful ever cuz it the most work in Chino
or Idaho those boys I heard but you know
but the thing is about it's still a
teenage thing I grew up on watching
those teenage movies the folks don't
look like me but I ain't owned you know
the whole thing of the teenage angst and
in this movie is still a very teenage
movie so I was like okay maybe you know
but not you know I think they turned it
down I had that family rate tre what
they turned it down usually they turn a
they turned it on yeah but but Jonathan
Demi to his credit was going to produce
a Jonathan Demi and his partner at SEC
snack they were going to produce it at
Orion and then Orion was folding at that
time and Orion actually Orion Pictures
actually it's in my office anybody'll in
my office I'm still not a person in this
in this whole business has office on
43rd and credit Shaw I have in my office
the coverage from Orion which says I
have no talent that I try too hard to
use the vernacular of the street and and
that you know whatever just pass right
and then it's right next to the coach
from Columbia Pictures I said in the
right hands of a good director this
could be a very very viable picture you
know I mean you know you know in the
vein of doing the right thing and so
forth right and boom and it says it
shows a lot of talent and so we went
with Columbia of course Steve was nobody
in the business really knows anything
you know I'm saying I think I think we
all know that now just from the John
Hughes conversation but see I have to
ask you how you came on to this well I
just finished working on the movie
misery which was an athlete title
project and my son was going from sixth
grade to seventh grade and I knew that
that summer I wanted to be with him
because I think when your kids get into
junior high that they begin the process
of walking away from their parents and
so my friend Billy Crystal asked me to
do city slickers I said no I'm
I'm gonna hang with the air in this
summer and so we had a family vacation
in Cambridge Massachusetts because Aaron
wanted to go to the Basketball Hall of
Fame and western mass and this
persistent little mosquito named
Stephanie Elaine called me and said I
just read the greatest script I've ever
heard in my life and you have to we have
to do this and I said you know I really
want this summer off and I you know she
said it so if you know Stephanie you
have to say yes just to get her to stop
calling you and so she she sent it to me
and The Criterion I think probably for
all of us is if you can read it in one
sitting
that's right I read it and and it was
like in my life you just I turned a page
and I and I was resisted the draft in
the Vietnam War I believe to this day
largely in social justice and the script
for boys in the hood really hit me the
way it hit Steph right in the gut and
this was something that had to be done
when we were working on this movie was
starting to move it everything I didn't
know anything I don't know anything I
thought I knew a lot about movies I
thought I was a smartass
film student I thought I knew everything
about movies and then they said okay
you're gonna make a movie that's when I
got scared so but but but all these
people led me through it Stephanie
shepherded the project and make sure
that they got a green light at Columbia
she hooked me up with Steve you know me
you know me and hook with Bruce but
Stephanie to her credits remember you
said okay the first day that shooting
they're going to want to hear you know
they're going to want to hear your voice
in the track directing right number you
said that right and I said what he made
so the after that I said no they want to
hear your voice in the background right
I never even seen rushes I had done just
silent films at USC so I would so I I
taught but but but it was great because
it gave me something work because I knew
we were working with the kids the first
week but I would talk to the kids and I
would say if I tell you something just
do what I say don't listen to me don't
look off and
so that helped me and I did that and we
were shooting in a neighborhood me and
Steve did something very very he's my
first producer he did something very J's
I thank you for this he specifically
scheduled the movie a lot of movies are
shot and out of continuity right but
this my first movie and he knew I was a
novice so he specifically scheduled the
movie in continuity and so as the movie
goes further along I'm learning how to
direct
so as the movie becomes more and more
intense and it comes on to the third act
you know Cameron Burke is more more
fluent similar that because I'm getting
better and better and I'm taking more
chances I'm like doing different things
and so I got to say thank you very much
for that Steve